la preuve l'oeil de l'oreille
l'histoire que nous raconte la musique
va et vient changea détail puis ajoute
un épisode oublié qui était
l'explication de tout le reste
renouer le fil et trouve la voie
le paysage que peint la musique se
transforme au filet au gré du temps
heures et saison climat la pluie
s'arrête soudain l'arc en ciel sur les
cascades annonce l'entrée des mines 1
le voyage où nous embarque la musique
prend un essor sur un fleuve dans les
berges ckfd de plus en plus avec des
rideaux de branches ou les oiseaux se
répondent en approchant de la mer
le visage que nous tracent la musique
ouvre des yeux sur un continent nouveau
où nous cherchons à le suivre par me
murmurer bruit chevelure et sourire dans
la surprise et les mois
le miroir que nous propose la musique se
fissure et oil man de fureur se
recouvrent de fumée qu'elle dissipe à
l'appel des anciens et des prochains
qu'elle fait parler pour nous
la pensée que nous suggère la musique
cherche un mot qui permettrait de nous
dire ce qu'on avait entrevu nous avions
cru le saisir il se dérobe et nous
laisse pantois dans l'obscurité
la lumière que diffuse la musique
s'insinue dans les gouffres qu'on
croyait leur être les plus hostiles dans
désespoir et torture nous révélant un
envers des cheveux longs pour nous
sauver
merci michel butor merci marco plan
michel venez nous rejoue